I turn to my right and I see I see a
winner I see a winner I see I see a man
who is for the brand I see a man who is
America's Sweetheart and and he's
Patrick McAfee here on the Rich Eisen
show good to see you sir
incredibly steep dropoff for your show
here Academy Award guy to me but I am
excited to be here it's always great to
get in this I appreciate that
you know and JK Simmons has won has won
the statuette has won the Oscar and that
said though did he play horse with Lamar
Odom on Venice Beach yesterday did me
give you a quick answer no and you did
that was funny yesterday and right in
the middle of like our two you turn to
me and you're like guess what's
happening right now I was like hey this
just popped up Pat's live in Venice
playing horse with Lamar Odom oh you
went you went under waited free throw
right there you went Rick berry on him
and he missed you thought you got a
letter on I had him at hor rich I had
him at hor and I lost it Tim McAfee send
me an incredibly hilarious text message
about how I let this one get away I will
never get to play Khloe Kardashian's
ex-husband and horse ever again and I am
completely defeated against them and
it's a real shame I had him on the ropes
well he went underneath the leg
left-handed layup and you just had no
answer are you are you lying that you
had no answer
I did there's all my athletic shorts
either those are my tight ones that's
what got me right there behind the back
the backboard you had no she out there
yeah how did this come about so a
sponsor mine a gambling website okay and
they have a we've been doing the show go
that's odd that Vegas would be the
connection between the you and Lamar
Odom that's kind of you know well
there's some stories to be told but yeah
a gambling website we do a show called
beat Pat McAfee every Thursday live at
noon okay and it's them setting odds on
whether or not I can accomplish a task
the little kids game perfection you know
returns dude yes I failed it so that's
one of the only times I've lost is that
perfection game and then yesterday
against Lamar Odom
I bowled last week I wrote a 177 so all
that be there was $50,000
but on whether or not I would break 131
77 I mean so you so so all those who
took the over or loving that love it
what's the so the perfection yes bad
well the perfection gamble would be can
you completed three attempts so like the
first one was like plus I think was like
a plus 500 if you bet on Pat beating
perfection the first time and then it
went down each time because they thought
I'd give I'd bite by second a third shot
of perfection you should have it yeah
Jesus said that but it was one of those
things where and on a jew i fee I got
that one I understood that one I'll say
I didn't wash along thank you sir I
appreciate that
so perfection what get you is it the
fact that it's that the pop-up thing is
or is it that you did the ticking the
this the you know the the noise of the
of the time are going so we learned last
time I was here that my childhood was an
interesting one right that's a lot of
sports like dad I had a DD so I was up
and Adam so I've never seen a Disney
movie growing up like I have no idea
about any of those things my lady now a
lot of emotion she talks about the
beauties and the beasts and all them and
I have no clue about any of it I get it
but I don't really so I never I never
played a lot of board games my a DD is
outrageous yes so they heard that the
the book he actually heard that and
they're like how we want you to try play
Charlie and I just don't have the
strategy I'm not smarter than a fifth
grader I have no idea how to do it and I
I lost by technicality but it was closer
to pull up in my face the last one
that's a lot of money but Lamar Odom
beat me and horse yesterday in the book
he made a lot of money okay yeah cuz
everybody bets on me I don't know why so
I just want to love because people you
like I said you're America's Sweetheart
people are rooting for you I'm not for
everybody
I'm off forever but you know you're an
acquired taste yeah well let's let's so
let's describe what we're what you're
wearing today let's start with the shirt
let's start with the shirt hey the shirt
a shirt is you with a goat head on it
now something it's that not you lose it
this is unbelievable rich you cover the
NFL you first employee of NFL Network
this person who scored the most Viteri
in the history of the NFL okay so it's a
goat Vinatieri shirt that you got going
this is an homage to him break
the points record and then around his
neck right there you see I got this
while playing right after playing Lamar
oh that's a gold chain that you're
wearing around your neck what is uh
what's the origin of this I think I'm
part of the chain gang now I think I'm a
chain guy now strictly because you're
not going to not buy a six dollar gold
chain from the homeless man at Venice
Beach after losing to Lamar Odom this is
a six dollar gold chain the guy told me
it was a hundred percent real I I feel
like I really won here a bargain yeah so
I'm a chain guide now it's it's good to
be here okay this is quite an evolution
of my life yeah and that the chain does
come down right around on the shirt the
the goat ahead of Venna Terry dis
Vinatieri have a shirt like this well
vinegar is Italian so I'd assume he does
wear chains like this a lot
this shirt oh sure I've ship this ship
all the shirts that I crave for Adam
Vinatieri so Maj I send to him as we
should by the way the guy's a living
legend hey man you didn't even know was
him though I was wearing my glasses I
couldn't see the the these are reading
glasses that I have on that I that that
I needed to take off I didn't see that
number was the number four well now I
see it since last time I was here yes
Pat and this is a change of subject
okay what you did in London that's
incredible don't you have to work every
day so you probably have to kiss the
ring a lot but watching the NFL Network
gasps to that with 15 people in the
booth Thanks I thought you handled that
like a maestro I appreciate that it's
really impressive you know what the guys
you know because people have have texted
me and email me with those sentiments
that I I handled it or what have you but
I couldn't keep those three guys from
not stepping on me or anything like that
they did a great job I wish you would've
got Michael Irvin like he was on on that
one morning but Irv Irv did not need a
towel man that day respect like like
Elvis that's what I said - when did the
next day when we saw him at the at the
meeting for game day morning you know
like we had he just went off in the
meeting and then I went up to him and
told him down
in the meeting and Kurt wasn't there cuz
I think he was coming back his son
caught four balls for Nebraska this past
week yeah he goes to watch his son he
his son's a walk-on at Nebraska yeah
Kate Warner's been killing it but any
rate and wide receiver wide receiver
relied receiver go for him I know see
he's been killing it so Kurt did it he
patted him down on gameday morning thank
you for saying that I really I really
want you to know you did well I
appreciate the makeup lady new lady mmm
same same I'll come here for the face I
think my mom's gonna be proud of what
we're looking well last time you were
here Sarah was not here I believe the
things you shared you know Sarah you're
an Indiana individual correct Sarah's as
well so there you go they don't know
that Indiana and Indiana right here I
mean you're still living in Indianapolis
correct its national Indiana Day to do
well what do you think of what the Colts
are doing right now I like what we're
doing I talked to crisp out I'm gonna
show two days ago hmm they are in a
really sweet spot Chris Ballard said
when I talked to him in training camp
that there's trying to build the culture
before bringing in big free agents right
so they had a lot of money to spend they
said they want to build the culture with
young players so that whenever a free
agent comes in they can fit in and I
think they're doing that right now that
Darius Leonard is a monster Quentin
Nelson obviously an incredibly talented
and viral offensive lineman whether it's
fake news or not and luck looks to be
back I like what they're doing they're
in a good spot so what you are you
referring to the the sound that was
placed on of him screaming as he's
hitting that that was not real correct
the sound was not of him just absolutely
destroying so I found out that was fake
after a Jaguar interview with Chris
Ballard yes and Chris alluded to it to
me like three times during the interview
that it was fake but I just didn't want
to believe it because that video was too
good I didn't want to believe that it
was fake it's on the internet it's not
fake yeah and that led to him being like
fine 25 grand I think because that video
was so big well I guess it was so big
and it looked like he was you know using
this the crown of his helmet to hit
somebody you know why was it but he was
he was a hell of a ball he still he's
dominant and and luck has been
ridiculous this year for somebody was
wondering if he was gonna play anymore I
have a guy that works with me every day
he's a huge Detroit Lions fan okay so
he's just a miserable human Eric Ebron
comes to the coats he's like oh this
guy's gonna suck for you guys this dude
is terrible
this guy is an overhyped guy you got
notion and then now he Braun is amazing
leading the league and tight ends and
everything and luck has found a nice
home with him it's very comfortable it's
a poutine and Doyle's back healthy and
obviously T Y as T Y and we're seeing
the red and luck hasn't been touched in
four weeks it seems which never I mean
we had we had 14 surgeries because he
was getting touched a lot there for a
while
now the the offensive line is coming
together Ryan Kelly's doing well well T
Y Hilton is an underrated individual
because he just quietly puts up huge
numbers right and Jack Doyle was once my
my blindside wing for the punt team
that's where he started that's where he
got his start he's a grinder he is it
now he's rich wealthy starting tight end
for the quotes he's in a good spot I
guess we got to get all this Colts love
out of our system because Titans lineman
and left tackle Terrell Owens gonna join
us in the next segment ad team I like
that team a lot that Titans team I do
too I like Vrabel a lot I like the way
he's doing things and Taylor has become
emerged as one of the like the best
leaders I think in football and whatever
he's doing everybody else when he came
out his boss hogg or whatever everybody
was behind it when he got his big payday
I think he's I think they got some
special down there Nash what do you
think Pat McAfee about Mariota
I think he's top he's he's top half of
the in quarterbacks in the league I
think he's figuring it out right I mean
he's never really had like a sturdy
scheme or a sturdy system around him the
exotic Smash Mouth is what they were
calling it the last couple of years of
the Mularkey era I tried to run an
exotic vehicle yesterday he's out very
expensive but the exotic Smash Mouth
could be awesome but if you start
looking at if he gets comfortable in a
system and he's got that good offensive
line chugging beers at natural predators
games they look like they're a tight
group there yeah and then you got a good
defense and in Vrabel seems to be making
the right decisions that could be a
really talented team and Mariota by the
way every quarterbacks only good if your
team's good if your team sucks every
year and never wins I mean not gonna be
considered a good quarterback so he's
gotta do is win everybody starts talking
about well he's a two-way threat he
throws a beautiful deep ball he just
needs to you know from what I'm hearing
and what I see that second read he's
just married to that first read pre snap
and it's very difficult for him to find
that second third guidepost snap more
often than not
but as a guy that played quarterback in
practice yes Pat practice squad reps
nice basically real-life Madden which is
what I was for the Colts there for a
couple years when you look at that card
it may have the one who ever it is the
ex I don't even know the name of it but
it's the left wide receiver and they
circle and they say this is the one
option and then the tight end is a two
option it's hard not to get married to
that first one whatever it's like hey
the play is set up for this person to be
open it's hard to be like you know what
but I want to go to this it's I think
that is something you're not granted I
was probably the best practice squad
quarterback I've ever seen
yeah all the time yeah if I had to guess
a lot of completions the week we played
the New Orleans Saints back in the day I
was acted as if I was Drew Brees just
Jimmy Graham was though Titan I threw
for 5,000 yards that week I knew we're
in for a big trouble and we were we lost
by 60 in the dome down there and I knew
it was coming because me and drew put up
the same numbers well when Peyton came
back to the Indianapolis you played him
that week because did you know you yeah
you had such command of the office I was
fourth down quarterback that night just
fourth down quarterback but in the let
me sling the wrong no they did not know
no the new regime thought I should just
go stand on the other field and practice
how to punt with Vinatieri and then go
in oh yeah Shea might a lot of fun in
practice when I was young in the first
couple years I was like I was literally
running scout team quarterback it was
hilarious there's one of those layers
things were a part of well I want to
take a break here and come back before
Taylor LaJuan joins us someone hit your
get your thoughts on two subjects and
I'll give them to you right here it's a
tease going to break I don't like
thinking about things much but I'll do
it for you okay well I mean you know
them but I've this is just for reminds I
for the listeners to stay tuned to
listen to Pat McAfee on what the
Steelers did to loving on bells
belongings all those Jays okay sorry all
right and then two and Oliver of the
University of Houston being told by
major Applewhite his coach to take a
jacket off because the jacket is only
supposed to be worn by active players in
the reaction from last night
yeah he didn't deserve that okay that's
Pat McAfee he's gonna join us went a
little Juan gets on the hog old buddy
should have had the jacket I just want
that I'm getting
out ahead of this one okay this'll be
fun stuff that's coming up next here on
the Rich Eisen show okay welcome back to
the show Taylor Luanne's about to chime
in here and before he does
Pat McAfee is gonna join us with that
ice hat you're hanging with us all our
number-3 oh come on
any time and thanks for let me know
you're in town if you'd let me know
you're in town you're welcome you're a
nice I could do so LaJuan as you know as
a Michigan man so I've known him for a
long time he's been on this show many
times but hasn't been on in a while I
used to I used to be able to with my one
of our show Booker's just call him
directly he's changed his number he's
rich now and well he's also unfollowed
me on Twitter what happened I don't know
I was pissed off of you at one point to
platform like we hear what you say you
know like I do you did something you did
you call it another punter I think it
was right I was having like the best
season of my life and he said something
it was something disparaging that you
didn't even know it was a Rick I took a
ricochet shot somehow and I was like
rich is the og of the punters of people
too he just took a shot I didn't follow
you I would never do that couldn't do
that because I but I was on the outs
unknown to me
yeah yeah this was a one-way hatred for
about a week or two yeah so this could
be what happened with Taylor well I
wasn't happy with you at one point
either because you took a shot at the
NFL Network man I did yes
broadside at the NFL Network and we have
been there
what made you guys better yes it's right
now you make us better by calling us out
or something like that but but we're all
good I mean that's what I'm saying I
think this is understand here's the way
I'm taking it I'm taking it sometimes
you know my my phones in my pocket and
I'll start like looking at my Twitter
feed I'm like when did I follow this
person I have no idea
mm sometimes it's a but follow I'm gonna
say it was a but unfollow you said he
accidentally unfollowed you that's the
only way I'm gonna take it without
taking it personally right I think we
should think about taking it personally
because that's a lot of work to get into
your profile to hit the on
follow button and I think they even ask
you like are you sure I think he has to
like triple down on it
the only follow us 525 people it's a lot
of people yeah let me see only but I'm
thinking there was a ricochet shot that
you don't even know happened that's one
things just send it out we're gonna have
to iron this thing out I'm glad you're
here you know you're the other your
peacemaker in that way but I have no
quarrel I'm the you know saya you're in
here you're neither unite unite people
hey by the way just just to let you know
I get my love of punting the NFL Network
research group just sent out a stat
which I didn't retweet it's my favorite
set of all time
oh I think I'm gonna like it since 1940
Tom Brady is the only player to throw
more passing touchdowns 50 then his
punter had punts in the season 44 and
this year with mahomes and Brees are
both on pace to accomplish the feat this
season as Colquitt and more sted are
kicking back those are two of the best
in the game - you're talking about
really Johnson punished that Colquitt
thing where he walks up to mahomes and
says hey thanks for letting me pun it
was nice getting back out there yeah
that's a hilarious line Thomas Moore
steady as well when I got there
Hunter Smith had a couple games were
Payton didn't let him punt yeah I never
experienced it I had a couple with one
but it's one of those situations where
as a punter we like to pride ourselves
on being the people you'd like to drink
a beer with yeah we are the people that
after a win you'd like to celebrate with
yeah I think Dustin and Thomas are both
very excited that they're just along for
the ride watching some greatness with
their team which is what mahomes and
Brees are doing this year yeah more
stats had two games including this past
week where he didn't pawn a single game
a single punt
it's unblinking greater this Joe people
forget great holds down there he's
holding those balls for mr. Lutz at an
impressive fashion all of his focus
turning to turning the laces to six from
there from 6 to 12 and with the proper
lean yeah but you just want to win
that's pressure though hold-hold oh I
was so scared I've never been more
scared in my life
I lied to Bill Polian face told him I
knew how to hold coming out of college I
did not I never got kicked in college I
can you lied to poll Ian's Very's mr.
pullian
yeah he asked me I don't know if it was
via phone ordering a workouts yeah thing
happened he was like you know how to
hold it
we were to draft you the punch right and
nobody was looking for me to punch I was
like absolutely yeah yeah absolutely
know how to do that and I had never done
it in my entire life so then I get
drafted Vinatieri knows that I was a
kicker in college he calls me the day
after he goes have you ever held before
I'm like Vinny I gotta tell you this I
lied right to mr. Boies by that point
I'd already been drafted
so our first lay our first conversation
was like a convert I like a
congratulations and then he was very mad
at me and then he sent me to a holding
camp in North Carolina with Ken Walter
the guy who held Forman doing it yeah
looks like a boot camp with Ken Walter I
say to this house yeah it was a wild
scene I was very nervous yeah first game
in the NFL I could give a damn about how
those punt 1 whenever I walked out to
hold for him I ain't never been more
nervous in my entire life I ain't never
I never been how's it going to do I had
one I had one or two bad ones my entire
career yeah boy well it's that boot camp
that's right it said boot camp just
straighten you out yeah I had I had
blisters on my fingers Terry would come
to my my room and training camp at night
and even throw me I'm like 500 balls a
night I would get thrown like he was it
was very much like hey kid I built up
quite a little legacy here I'm not gonna
let you come in here because you lied to
Bill Polian space I'm like hey I'm with
you dawg
so we became really good friends over
that but yeah it is an interesting
conversation your first ever game was a
1412 win over Jacksonville yeah that
sounds right it's a lot of holding to to
yeah it's about to say but I'll tell you
what those two holds I might as well
have been the Superbowl game winning
kicks I was scared out of my mind I was
getting texts from my friends like I
hope you do well today don't ruin
Vinnie's career I'm like thanks that
means a lot you can do that you guys
started 14 I know that year that we
didn't lose until we chose to that's by
the way a thousand percent what happened
I know yeah I was there took a knee on
an undefeated season man yeah I was too
young to have an opinion but boy all the
heads in the locker room were not happy
we're not happy no because the 72
dolphins still get talked about that was
something like if we can go get it we
should go get it but then it's thinking
ahead we win that Super Bowl after
resting that game everybody looks like a
genius we lose the Drew Brees we've
talked about this before
I don't think his kid now is stupid but
the baby celebrating after that was very
dumb so it's one of those things where
it's the old head though jeez wanted to
go for it and I was just I was too young
to have a dessert again I understand
losing a Super Bowl leaves a mark that
never goes away but to blame it on a
small child who's a beautiful child with
headsets on it drew brees did a great
job making a beautiful baby and those
babies were on ESPN last week that's
very smart they're very very intelligent
but the last image I saw before walking
into the most miserable locker room I've
ever been in in my entire life which was
after that Super Bowl I was so young I
was like no big deal we'll be back next
year guys nice no big deal we'll just
come back next year this isn't a big
deal that was not that locker room was
the most miserable place I've ever been
in my entire life in the last thing I
saw before walking in there a baby with
the thing and I was like that that Bay
it's like Pavlov's dogs I see that baby
miserable world yep there it is on
screen right there yep that was the last
thing I was on the Jumbotron while we
were walking into the locker room filled
with misery I think like Payton left the
country for like a month it was like the
most miserable place ever well before
lawan calls what'd you think of the
steelers locker room where all Alevi on
stuff got tossed around as soon as he
said he wasn't coming back that was wild
what that whole situations very loud to
me because NFL locker room NFL players
are all about people getting their money
right get your money do your thing
there's no business we don't do business
in the locker room that's not it's not a
you can get into a lot of petty
arguments whenever you start talking
about people's money how much people are
making how much they're not playing
things like that like Dwight Freeney was
making 17 mil I think the first year
Gregson was there and they were only
playing him on some third downs like he
wasn't even playing and frame even knew
like this I am sorry basically you just
use don't talk a business in the locker
room so whenever that whole offensive
line came out and people are taking
shots at him that was very weird to me
it was all very interesting and then now
that he's officially decided not he do
up which i think is a bad decision for
the future I'm neither here nor there
he's gonna fire his agent at some point
do you think so I think so I think
that's the only way he saves us III
think that's only PR spin here to save
as I was beginning I was given wrong
information so that nano fell teams
because there's a lot
the people that aren't gonna be happy
that he just skipped out on an entire
season I I like who like potential
suitors what's right thing III think
everybody's like well all you need is
one all you need is one right people
ever say but in negotiation you need
more than one actually you need that's
that's not the way if he wants to get 42
million which I think is what he needs
to get if he wants to make back this 14
and a half I don't you need a couple
teams interested I think this is a bad
look especially with his locker getting
looted by his teammates right after
leaving that's insane well even if they
were just joking around that was doesn't
that say something I don't if they were
to be like hey Liv like we'll send you
your stuff like I think that would that
would be a funny thing but it was an
interesting video especially after the
old line came out and took shots at him
that's a that's a very interesting
situation I'm excited to see how it
plays out but I think Liv eventually
ends up firing his agent PR spin I was
giving wrong information blah blah blah
do you think he were you surprised that
he didn't text Ben back he hasn't texted
most of his guys in that locker room
yeah because you think you're still
friends with those that every time
somebody retires they always say they
missed the locker room right I missed
the locker room I missed the guys I miss
being in an NFL locker room with the
guys my small business is like 10 guys
so we're kind of like a locker room to
begin with every single day but guys
missed the locker room they missed the
friendship that is the interesting thing
that he hasn't really because I still
got boys that play on other teams we
still talk and things like that but
every situation is different and
especially whenever you're a
once-in-a-generation running back when
like you're you think you are or you're
being told it's it's a whole different
situation Pat McAfee here in the Rich
Eisen show by the way it would be really
cool just to be able to say nah the 14
and a half million - right that'd be
awesome
you know I thought about it yeah I'm
gonna make a rap song but but instead
I'm gonna make a point about what I
think my value is that's what he's
saying
I know it's good business right it's
it's it always seems like business can
be business like Aaron Donald right
there's a business guidance it sits out
awhile and Dominik and sue was
considered a business guy over there for
a while I mean you look at Darrelle
Revis he's probably the best business
NFL player in the history of the game
ever ever ever ever ever like to hired
as a mercenary basically what's coming
maybe that's what will happen with Lev
bail but
fourteen and a half is a wild number to
just walk away from and have to make up
and earn well he said in her in a
freestyle in his front yard shirtless
last year he wants 17 m/s so he wanted
17 million you say that is if you
nobody's ever made a shirtless video on
their front lawn before I mean Terrell
Owens essentially is the king of the
shirtless video on the front lawn angry
and that workout is something that
really isn't rice I've never done that
intensive workout in my front yard or
inside a house I'm very impressive
something else he's all a Famer how do
you guys feel at the NFL Network about
him being a Hall of Famer not doing
booty to you you we talked about it here
I thought he made a mistake so once
that's a really big opportunity look he
he's not gonna change the way that the
the selectors select people and he's not
gonna change the way that it's set up
for selectors to select people what he
did was deny himself that incredible
weekend you only get one induction
ceremony he's unbelievable he obviously
had something that he wanted to get
across and get off his chest and make
the point of but you know I was watching
your post show you in the hundred go
jackets yeah and I think Randy and Ray
were basically like pleading with him
like come home cuz they're planning on
doing a lot with no I mean and and then
the got there they'll be you know a
quick moment where he's gonna have to
look other you know oh geez in the face
and say I wasn't disrespecting you and
then welcomed with open arms and
hopefully he comes back every year
because that's uh but that's the reason
why it works is everybody comes back
I do think Tio's been disrespected for
what he does on the field but I think
he's brought a lot of distractions along
with him so I think it's kind of like uh
you know like pros I'm sure but he's one
of the old-time greats and and the stuff
off the field of whatever he was doing
is exactly why he wasn't first ballot
and I think he wanted to make a point
and unfortunately for him like I said
there's nothing like that weekend I
watched him playing a beer league
softball game out here in LA three years
ago he jumped over a guy and landed on
third base he's unbelievable Marie
Kathleen the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience